did that explode on your leg yeah
sandals died Circle Circle
I got an idea eeny meeny miny moe catch
the tiger by his toe if he hollers let
him go
told me to pick the very best one you
can like you can cry
yeah you're all going to be
[Music]
so it's beautiful day out I'm going to
pick up a jump 360 camera rig from the
YouTube space down in Santa Monica
the Google jump camera that we're
supposed to pick up did not arrive in
time so Nick might be driving towards
the YouTube space right now and there's
not going to be anything there for him
how's it going man I'm here to pick up a
jump 360 Rick for corridor Oh what call
Nicola Ron that's probably already there
I know I'm just gonna tell Nick hey I
just got an email the camera is not at
the YouTube space right now it's not
there it's not shipped yet they [ __ ]
up if there's just any cameras there we
can get that be cool just so you don't
come back empty-handed or maybe you see
me t-shirts I know they have a lot of
candy there too Thanks oh I love him
thank you put me and I'll give one to
run by he sound really defeated what
this supposed to be it
okay yeah Norris I was just about to
give up but one of the guys there he
overheard he said just wait one second
let me run some tests on this rig I do
have here it's the same exact one he was
able to hook us up with 360 jump rig
Thank You Lee Bora for going above and
beyond to get us that rig now we can go
ahead on this project as planned
I heard you're looking for a 360 camera
rip oh I want the cameras 16 of them
we're talking about 16 GoPros arranged
in a configuration that allows us to
shoot 360 degrees and 3d at the same
time this is the GoPro Odyssey rig I
thought this is a jump ring jump is the
software the Odyssey is the rig oh okay
cool going to be shooting a video with
this rig in collaboration with YouTube
they're like hey your wallet video is
cool what if you took it to the next
level with this rig here what a beast
that's more GoPros I think we've owned
as a business in our entire careers the
way this thing works is you put it down
on a tripod you hit a button and record
a bunch of footage with it you upload it
to Google servers and then they process
it and spit back files that you can use
there's very little work involved from
what I hear
[Music]
don't get too distracted if you want to
get good at After Effects you've got to
get good at shortcuts and by that I mean
what tools do use often use the pen tool
often I know what shortcut that is is
jeep do you know we do want to go back
to the selector tool I know what button
that is is me ctrl alt F to resize
whatever layer you have to beat the
composition size the reason why this is
important is because let's say you spend
an entire day doing effect shots you
don't use any shortcuts you just go up
to the menu go down you look for it and
you do shortcuts keeps you in the moment
longer I don't have to take my eyes off
whatever image I'm looking on to go look
for whatever tool that I need it's just
a combination of letters and keys on
your keyboard that in combination select
a tool /the same thing as selecting a
hammer off of your wall imagine you're
at a workbench and you have tools on the
wall but in order to work on the next
part of the project you have to get up
go get the hammer
sit back down
you're like okay where was I right okay
take the nail hit it a bunch and then
you can continue working if I had
shortcuts I could just use this hammer
I don't have to spend any mental
faculties thinking about what tool you
have to use where it is it doesn't take
that much time but a shortcut will take
that action from say like maybe three
seconds down to under half a second and
over the course of the day that can add
up to upwards of like maybe 15 or 20
minutes here is you and here's the
effect you're working on all this stuff
in between are the tools you use to make
the project the more you can reduce the
time using the tools or importantly
reducing the time finding the tools the
sooner you can get to that final product
which will also because you got to there
sooner will be better don't try to
memorize all the shortcuts in one day
that's impossible I don't even know all
the shortcuts but all the tools that you
use most often try finding what shortcut
there is for that and just try using it
little by little force yourself every
time you go up and look for the tool be
like know what does a shortcut is gonna
take more time to begin with and that's
okay because you're learning it and once
you have learned it you'll be more
connecting with what you're making and
that's what matters at the end of the
day is being connected with your artwork
when you have a train of thought you can
move forward regaining that train of
thought when you lost it is really hard
and that takes time
that's why shortcuts are so important
because it keeps you in the work longer
done a mess we're doing this 360 Wizard
video with the jump er egg we're gonna
do a quick test to see how fireworks
show up on camera during the day all
cameras react differently to light if we
can shoot this video during the day
instead of the night I'll be a big help
let's take a look I tried turning it off
and back on again I've never seen that
issue before array era why the [ __ ] am I
getting in a race and retching it up
whoa there you go it worked
here we go how can this go wrong to go
wrong if I get a little Bernie embers
burning to ourselves or we burn the
camera the chances of anything going
wrong are so and I don't want to get hit
my fireworks are to be flying in your
direction
oh go you can go you son of a [ __ ]
Circle Circle
it's chaos hey I can sweep over here
totally sweet edit directed on Sam's
like oh yeah right here that's where
that's what happens you anything up here
so did that explode on your leg
yeah stand all this died I almost time
in my life I'm here with Sawyer Hartman
he came out to visit the set she let me
let me show what your Oh
so I reached out like hey what are you
guys doing and I was like well Sam and I
are shooting a 360 wizard battle video
with a lot of fireworks with a launcher
a lot of fireworks and so I was like
that's neat but then I mentioned that we
have a prototype 3d 360 rig from Google
that has 16 GoPros and Sawyer was like a
mom away oh my god why don't we should
do that with red cameras sometimes 16
red cameras on a circle you'd be like 40
K you guys have no clue what's about to
happen like yeah I think it sprayed down
so no cash thank you providing right
yeah you're welcome
now sorry you've been doing a video
every day this past year right yeah a
Monday 183 where are some of your
favorites so far I was in China for a
little I got like sent there to like do
drone footage over the great wall that
was cool and then spent a long time in
Hawaii I just like adventuring you know
with cameras equal shots mostly had cool
videos talking about hello lords channel
a link somewhere is around here probably
the description see because I use
shortcuts I didn't even have to take my
eyes off the hit month all without
really
a shortcut is the equivalent of this
thing way over here C equivalent of this
being way over there and then C would
love the bat being way there for nothing
there for nothing my own ears